foreign
good evening members
welcome to this meeting of the audience
audit committee
I will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion by your
nearest fire exit
the two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use due to
ongoing works
therefore the fire exits are through the
main doors of the hall or the storeroom
adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the
roundabout the island in front of the
main entrance to the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer
members when I invite you to speak
please ensure you have one of the
microphones in front of you before
speaking as the microphones are needed
for the hearing Loop and for the audio
recording
these are not all these are switched on
ready for you to speak so you don't not
need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for four
then against recommendations those
abstaining from voting will be noted by
officers
agenda item one
apologies for absence
apologies for absence have been received
from councilors Mrs Tony Carter
Andrew cross and Michael Carter
substitute members Mrs Christine Mason
is substituting for Mrs Carter
Mr Newport is substituting for Mr Cross
and that's it yeah
um
councilor Lawman isn't here
agenda item three
non-members attending there are none
agenda item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 28th
of July 2022
are the minutes agreed members
grade
agenda item five
to receive Declarations of Interest
there are none
gender item six
audit progress report 2022-2023
Mike Porter will introduce the report
thank you very much
the report provides members of an update
in terms of the work of internal
auditing progressing the audit plan for
2022-23 and the action taken by service
departments in progressing audit
recommendations if I can ask members to
turn to enclosure one of the report
which is at 6.4
in terms of delivery annuity plan for
the for 2223 we have completed a total
of two audit engagements from the plan
and further complete
um two Grant claims which weren't
identified in the original plan
the first quarter of the year is very
much about the finishing up the work
from the previous year
before we commence work on the housing
benefits subsidy claim
um just to update members in terms of
the work of the housing benefits subsidy
claim is a significant piece of work
which takes between 25 and 30 days of
the audit plan available
um I can also update members in terms of
progress in terms of the HP subsidy
itself it's nearing its completion of
the 42 um claims we've required to um
investigate 40 are now complete so we've
only got two claims to further look at
and we've only found one error to date
in terms of the plan itself and
delivering the plan I'm into
staff in shortages we are proposing a
change to the plan in terms of the
actual plan in terms of taking out 60
days from the original plan that was
agreed by members as it highlights the
report we're currently carrying 1.5 ftes
in terms of vacancies and despite a
number of campaigns to recruit to the
vacant post as yet we've not been able
to fill those those posts
we are thus putting forward a number of
best case worst case scenarios that will
be a highlighted four scenarios here in
terms of further adjustment that might
be required to the plan should we not be
able to fill those vacant posts
we still have a of an effort out at the
moment and we're hoping to fill those
pose by November if that's not the case
we will come back to this committee
highlight what further changes we need
to make to the plan
the report also highlights the work of
service departments we Implement
internal audit recommendations there are
total of 15 live recommendations and
service departments are progressing well
in the implementing those
recommendations
since the the report was produced a
perfect two recommendations have been
implemented
the report also highlights the work of
the compliance team based in refs and
Ben's in terms of basically identifying
fraud and the savings made from that
work
as you can see from the report
significant savings have been made in
relation to both council tax and
business rates
in terms of the the audits that we're
complete from the plan we completed
transparency code and freedom
information we combined both those
audits into a single audit review which
received an adequate Assurance rating in
terms of compliance with a transparency
code we are compliant with the code in
terms of the information we publish and
we also meet our requirements in respect
of the freedom information requests
as noted in a report
we are sometimes outside the the number
of days allowable in terms of
progressing those fir requests but those
delays are not significant
I'm happy to take any questions in
relation to my report
yes can you tell me which um
the further two that have been finished
since the report yes
there's the asset management
recommendation
number one
the property inspection racing will be
fully reinstated this is now now the
case that recommendation is being
implemented
can you sorry can you tell me what pages
Asset Management are number one yep
so that's been completed that's been
completed yes sorry I just need to keep
up with with what you're saying what was
the second one um the second one's the
health and safety
um recommendation recommendation number
four
this is Paige
uh
that's fine it's a route for everything
awesome
6.23 sorry
oh number 12 yeah
yeah thank you
councilor Mason
I hope I get this right
thank you chairman
I've got a couple of questions do you
want me to take them in order or
throw them all out in one no one at a
time please okay just so I'd warn you
there are at least two maybe three
I'd like to to start with the report
um item of item six and I'm interested
in paragraph 3.2
which in particular refers to
the necessary opinion of the chief audit
executive or otherwise known as CAE and
that opinion is obviously pivotal
I also took notes as Mr Porter Drew to
our attention
in closure number one
and in particular the scenarios at 1.7
where we had
have four scenarios around resourcing
I would like to know and be assured
that in any of those scenarios were they
to occur that there wouldn't be any
difficulty with the CAE providing a good
opinion
okay
if we were unable to fulfill those
vacancies there are other options
available to us so we can recruit
um accountancy firms to basically
backfill those days so in order to
provide an audit opinion we we will look
to basically complete sufficient audits
for the two forward executive to provide
an opinion that might ultimately mean
that we will have to buy in audit days
for an external resource to provide
sufficient work to provide that opinion
so if we cannot recruit
come November that is what I will be
tasked to be looking at in terms of
actually what days can we buy you know
who from so we might have to go to the
market in terms of finding an
accountancy body that can deliver those
days but rest assured we will provide
sufficient resources and delivery of the
plan to provide an opinion the plan
itself is risk Focus risk based so there
are particular audits which we highlight
as category one but need to be done in
order to provide that opinion so audits
generally around key financial systems
risk and governance are those ones that
are key to provide that audit opinion
there's other audits that that we may
wish to carry out but they're not so key
to learn to providing the overall
opinion in relation to risk governance
and internal control so we will ensure
that those key audience will be
delivered for Rochester Council and that
may mean that we may have to go to the
market to get those days brought in
thank you I'll I'll leave that question
there until November uh if we we have
hit some unfortunate scenarios will
obviously be be looking to fund those
additional costs in some way
so that will be a further issue to be to
be considered then yes I mean some of
those costs would be obviously offset by
the fact we don't have staff so
basically our staffing costs are reduced
so those reduced Staffing costs because
we don't have to replace people in post
we'll be used to basically Buy in those
additional resources
can I ask my second question yes please
my second question concerns the plan
itself and Mr Porter just very helpfully
engaged in the fact that the plan has to
support this the caes opinion
there is one area that I'm very
concerned
may not be included in the plan
the reason I say may not it's um it may
have been referred to in a different way
a way that I haven't recognized
you may or may not be aware that the
council does have a list a register of
motions passed by the council
I have I have a copy of of that of that
document which we've obtained through
another member asking the same questions
as myself
and I want to ask why that's never been
audited because
the risk that I have identified in
reviewing that register is that the
council has not been progressing motions
for some years
so I'd like to ask the question
is it in the plan
and if it's not in the plan why isn't it
and can it be added please
um it's not in the plan the plan was
agreed in consultation with senior
officers
um So the plan has been consulted on and
the items that are in the plan have been
agreed both by senior officers and by
this committee so the plan was presented
I think it was back in March to this
committee so at that point in time
members could have asked for for further
I think my attention to be added to the
plan
um it's not in the plan the plan the
plan is flexible all players are
flexible and they're risk-based if we
consider it a significant risk and we
would have to look into it we could
potentially put that in the plan and
substitute that for another item but we
would need to understand the particular
reasons or why we would want to include
that in the plan and then and then come
back to you so we would need to
understand why that's now
escalated into a significant risk and
perhaps why originally it wasn't put
forward by either Senior Management or
members to include in the plan so the
plan as I say has been discussed with
senior officers and it was presented to
to members back in March I believe it
was so at that time that the questions
could have been raised at that time I
mean as I say the plan is flexible and
and so we can take a fresh look at the
plan because it's it's an emerging
involvement world so you know risk
new emerging risk to arise and then
those are the ones we can look at to
include in the plan
can I come back on that please chairman
yes
um what is I mean there are two parts to
my supplemental on that is what are the
procedures that should I should now
adopt to have that item considered
and in the second I wish to say I was
not a member of this Council in March
having rejoined the Council on election
I expressed an interest in seeing what
the council had been doing for several
years while I was on retirement as it
were and on receipt of that list I
became aware of at least one if not many
items that have never been proceeded
I regard that
as a risk to the council I regard as a
reputational and other risks
so could you outline for me I've drawn
it to the attention of the chief
executive I've drawn it to the attention
of the Strategic director Mr Summers
and
um I would like to know now how I should
proceed
to have that added to the audit plan
okay in terms of any to the plan I think
the procedure would be to discuss that
with the chair and and essentially if
that's the agreement of the committee
and the committee feels that that is an
item to be included in the plan and then
then we could take take a look at it but
it has to have to be raised with a chair
and that would have to be the consensus
of the committee to include that item in
the plan
I'm not sure whether Naomi wants to add
anything
eternally and just check but yeah I
would agree with Mark's assessment that
I think it would come back
decide whether the plan is going to be
amended or nothing that would probably
be the appropriate form to bring it back
to the next meeting so that would be the
next committee it wouldn't be I don't
think it's waiting to change us now but
the next committee we could discuss that
and have a vote on it yeah
are you happy if we do that
no I'm I'm not German because
I regard the failure to take forward
important motions passed by the council
as a significant risk I have encouraged
asked the chief executive since July to
take
urgent and significant action and none
has been taken
I've had to pursue this individually for
the last three months
I'm not happy at all that the council
isn't running reputational risk which it
should not be doing
I think we know we know what you're
saying in your opinion but I think as I
say we need to
um take that back and agree as a
committee so I don't think we'll be
making any changes to the plan is we we
couldn't vote on it tonight I don't
think it's appropriate I think it's
better to take it away and bring it back
chairman um I'll make a proposal I'll
move a proposal if I don't think I'm
using the correct terminology but I'll
move that this committee adds an audit
an internal audit of the Motions
register with utmost
urgency in in particular deriving an
action plan for motions to be pursued
and performed and delivered
what
happened
thank you
can I just add impactful terms obviously
even if it even in theory that is added
to the audit plan I don't think it's
going to be carried out before the next
audience committee anyway so I think in
Practical terms it's not going to make
any real difference whether the decision
is taken tonight or at the next meeting
so and as I say we haven't got absolute
clarity about the governance process for
um raising that's not anyway I'm just
argue that in pragmatic terms it makes
more sense if we say bring it back to
the next committee for a decision
but we have chairman I will second that
motion yeah
um
oh you want to speak to speak to the
motion if I'm there
I think
um when we are advised as Council Mason
has of a reputational risk and a great
one motions through the council and the
ones that we have been identified I've
actually drawn some of them to the
attention of a portfolio holder they're
not motions just like um other groups
the emotions like all groups
and if the council is going to the
effort of making a political decision
and saying it would do something and the
council has an agreement and then years
later nothing is done that is a risk and
I do think this committee one of the the
elements of this committee is risk
assessment and I don't I think it should
be looked at urgently
and dealt with tonight as well thank you
thank you councilman Mrs Mason
well we have no reason not to take this
to the vote
so
oh sorry councilor Council
um I'm quite happy to take the officer's
advice that has nothing will be
happening over the next between now and
the next meeting then and if this has
been going on for some time and I don't
do not see an immediate risk so though I
agree with my fellow councilors that
there are risks and we need to look into
that and reputational risks and I
totally agree with him but I do think
there's time we need time there's a
community of order we're talking to the
motion
and the counselor isn't talking to the
motion well I'd like to say that I can't
support this motion at the time at this
time but I'm happy at the next meeting
anybody else want to speak
I'll take the vote
um
can we vote for the motion please
against
foreign
that motion has been carried so we would
like that put onto the uh the plan phase
okay
right
we'll carry on with um questions on the
uh
the report are there any further
questions
finish
I I hadn't but German I wanted to thank
um Naomi in particular for
arranging for further information to be
provided to me
on the transparency code and the foi
audit
those matters that I have been looking
at there don't affect the outcome of the
audit but again
it will be a matter I'm taking up with
the chief executive
thank you that wasn't a question but
thank you
councilor Mrs Mason uh thank you chair
um I just would like
um a couple of points one is a very
small one you say you've only picked up
one area I'm assuming it was an
insignificant error and not a major one
um at this point in time is something
that will be looked at by external audit
we just flagged that as an error race in
terms that it means an overpayment in
benefit which would be result in the
reduction in the XP subsidy but our
results and conclusion there's an inject
back Stone and audit so there's a
there's a check on our working effect to
make sure we've got it right
um so until they have concluded their
work we won't know the true extent of
that okay so yes and I think you've
answered my question it was basically a
routine error rather than anything yes
else thank you and the other thing I'd
just like some clarity here in case I'm
missing something uh please Madam
chairman
um on page 6.6 item 3.2
it says a total of four recommendations
and certainly in the report it says and
I've lost it now somewhere it says there
will be training required on the Freedom
of Information Act and yet the
recommendations only have four and the
training on the Freedom of Information
Act appears to have been lost although
I've lost the page where that was on I'm
sure I'm sure the officers can find it
quicker than me
yeah sorry page 6.12 it says here there
appears to be no training currently
provided to staff relating to foi and
eir requests formally understood to be
part of the HR corporate induction
training Etc
um a recommendation has been raised to
address this that I couldn't see the
recommendation on the recommendations
so unless I'm missing something um can
it be added on
it might be an oversight on our path
that's fine
I would have hoped the recommendations
if we add that on that recommendation
for thank you that's just the only Point
thank you I'm glad it wasn't me mistakes
do happen thank you councilman yeah
having had some experience of being on
the receiving end of the request for
Freedom of Information when I was in
full employment
we what is the process at RDC because we
had from my experience we had training
and then you would receive to your desk
something that was something to do with
your work that
and that may be part redacted before you
get there and then you're asked to
comment on it you we were given 14 days
in the in the model we had but you had
to have somebody supervising that
because we've got about one in 12 over
running
um here which is 40 out of was it 200
555 it's not an insignificant number of
sort of disgruntled people that'd be
waiting on the receiving end of that for
a reply so
that needs some governance does it not
that's what I was going to ask what is
the process how do we we monitor it and
who's responsible
yeah and there is a page on the
council's website which um if you just
search for in Hawaii it clearly states
all the um
governance and procedures that um apply
to Apple wireless
legislation and there is clear protocols
and procedures about how we should be
dealing
with we report on performance routine
now on the council
um if you want to go away and have a
look at that and then if there's any
further follow-up questions I'm sure
Angela and Laura and her team will be
happy too it really wasn't any more at
the enforcement of all of those
regulations to keep that number really
low
because uh it can be really aggravating
uh if we find we've got a significant
number of 1 in 12 is
considered a number of requests we go oh
sorry yeah that's what what I when I was
meaning not about the actual detail on
the website it's the actual physical
follow-up to make sure they go out on
time and let and if they cannot there
has to be some good reason for it yeah
sorry in terms of a process if we can't
meet the deadline then the individual is
is notified of the fact that we can't
provide that information
usually they will go over that day
because of the complexity of the
information we've got to provide so
where there's a lot of information to
pull back across a number of different
service departments it usually means we
can't meet that 20-day deadline so we
would go back to the person who raised
the request and say unfortunately we
can't meet the deadline rest assured we
will provide that information as soon as
possible so more often than not you find
the ones where they've gone beyond that
deadline is because of the nature and
complexity information required ones
where they're straightforward we will
meet that Target so
from based on our piece of work in the
audience we did what we found is where
we missed the deadline that is due to
the nature of the work and complexity
and how much information we have to pull
back but what we found is the the
individual was always notified of the
fact that we couldn't meet that deadline
so and not left waiting or thinking what
is happening with my request so they
would be informed to say yes it's in
hand it's a lot of information we can't
meet that deadline
yeah I think so thank you
yes I'm just a little bit confused
um saying that Freedom of Information
isn't on here but on page 6.20 it does
say review of arrangements for handling
requests
all priorities and it says it's
completed
is that
0.2 looking at the record
612 refers to 6-2
it says
and it's missing it says a
recommendation has been raised to
address this the recommendation we call
this committee there's three
recommendations and that one is missing
I think Mr Porter agreed that it has
been omitted in error I I will take a
fresh look at basically so the two tie
up I haven't really a missed to do the
reconciliation between what the report
was saying in the number of
recommendations but I will take that
away and have a fresh look at that to
make sure the two tie up you know
basically number wrecks in the report
tie up with the recommendation table so
you don't want to add the recommendation
on tonight I thought that I mean yeah I
mean I think that would be I will update
it yeah this is missing I'll make sure
it's updated yes I will take that on
board
are we presume we're going to vote on
these recommendations tonight so the
reports just coordinating so it's not
it's not yeah
so I'll I will update the report and
make sure it's basically correct
that's so I'd still like some clarity it
says it proposed that the committee
resolves that's not noticing
yeah I'm reading 6.2
the recommendation is proposed that the
committee results but the conclusions we
notice at the update if it doesn't mean
the training is not on there so we don't
know if that was three noted or
implemented
I I I will I will go back and and make
sure the recommendation if it's missed
and it's not it's basically I will
ensure it is brought up today
which is what you just wanted it noted
tonight not implemented no not approved
all the recommendations are to be noted
yes it was just the mission I didn't
know it was to be noted or enacted thank
you I worked on it I'll make sure it's
correct are there any further questions
no
um
we've got three
um proposals to be noted
are we happy to take those on block
yes
right
so it is proposed that the committee
resolves number one that the update on
delivering the 2022-23 audit plan
together with revised audit plan at
appendix 3 be noted
number two that the conclusions and
results from completed audit engagements
in appendix 2 be noted
and number three that the updated status
of audit recommendations in appendix 4
be noted
those members in favor can you please
raise your hands
that is
unanimous you've made lower your hands
thank you members
this concludes the business of the
meeting and the meeting is closed at 8
04 pm
thank you very much